Speaker 1: Hey, David, you've been covering
some of Trump's 20, 21 rallies.
Do you think his twenty, twenty one rallies
will be as effective as they were in twenty
sixteen?
So a couple of different things.
The point of the twenty twenty one Trump rallies
is very different than 2016 and 2016.
Trump was running for president in twenty
twenty.
Trump was running for president.
The rallies were about vote for me.
Sometimes begrudgingly he would say, OK, maybe
vote for some of these senatorial or congressional
candidates that came out as well.
But basically it was vote for me right now,
although we can imagine that the point of
the Trump rally from last week or the one,
you know, whatever the next one's going to
be, it's sort of to set up a twenty, twenty
four run.
Really, it's something else.
It's one to feed Trump's ego, which has been
significantly damaged by being kicked out
of the White House by Joe Biden.
So it's an emotional thing for Donald Trump.
Number two, it is setting up the grift of
donating money to the PAC or however they're
organized, where Trump will decide who are
the good Republicans.
Not the rhino's worthy of my support of your
support.
That's going to be a part of it.
And then three, it will be to still be the
decider, but less as a candidate and more
as the person that will give what he considers
to be a very valuable endorsement to twenty,
twenty two candidates.
And there's a couple differences also between
now and 2016 in terms of Trump's perception
in 2016.
Trump was basically sort of an eccentric celebrity
and there were lots of people who just wanted
to be in close contact with Trump and that
drove interest in Trump in 2015 2016 and made
the rallies maybe more powerful than they're
going to be right now.
There is more Trump fatigue at this point.
And in addition to that, there are also more
people who are kind of over the celebrity
aspect of Trump.
And I mean, if you're at this point, if you're
under 30, I would say if you're under twenty
six, you really see Trump more as that president
guy who's no longer president, then as a real
estate mogul in the 80s in New York City.
And there is some sense I have that again,
I go back to it because I think it's so dangerous,
Ron, to send this is a guy who could really
challenge Trump, not just in an electoral
sense, if it came to it in twenty, twenty
four.
But he has a lot of the same horrible authoritarian
tendencies as Trump, but he's more competent
and he's a better speaker.
And this makes him, I believe, significantly
more dangerous.
The problem for some, in some sense for Republicans
is that for now they're stuck with Trump as
a leader, whether they want him or not, until
someone else surfaces.
So even though we can poll Republicans right
now and, you know, 70 percent say they'd vote
Trump again, 30 percent say they wouldn't.
That 30 percent has not coalesced around anyone
in particular.
And if and until that happens, Trump Trump's
control of the Republican Party is his for
the taking.
He will never let go of power.
He will he'll bring down the ship with him.
And in a sense, he did.
Right.
I mean, the Republican Party lost the House
in twenty eighteen, the Senate in twenty twenty,
the White House in twenty twenty.
Under Trump, Trump sees himself as great for
the party he talks about his endorsements
are worth so much, et cetera.
So Trump will destroy the party if it's up
to him, will someone remove him from that
position of power?
And in the end, the rallies are going to be
more of a revenue generating activity and
a way to placate Trump's broken ego than they
are, at least in twenty, twenty one.
Electorally significant for Donald Trump.
That's my sense.
If you see the modern Trump rally is something
different, then let me know.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
How do you get the bonus show?
It's so easy.
You just sign up it.
Join Pakman Dotcom.
That is it.
Sign up it.
Join Pakman Dotcom, use the coupon code better.
Twenty one if you would like.
And we will see you in mere seconds on today's
business.